foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ah I don't want the trailer there we go
hello
yo before the stream started we had some
hot debates in the chat
in the offline chat
happy happy Monday blue eyed hello
hello Miro Vince Robert AMV Halcyon
Raymond Brian what's up guys
how we doing today
happy Monday
when is soon I need to know do you need
a clock
on the screen mate
you need a clock
what up Esther Samantha hello
[Music]
Trey brought up a very interesting topic
right at the beginning
saying I'm gonna say something
controversial Elden ring isn't an
incredible game Graphics are great fight
style is great
but the story isn't great the constant
lore debates proved my point
[Music]
that is so loud
yeah I mean I don't disagree with that
at all I really don't
we gotta move chat and stuff because
it's a different game
I think I just gotta move it down a
little bit there we go
pulls out Sky's gloomy stream television
let's go let's go Garrett I love it man
Irene Ryan I don't know how to say her
name I'm sorry
[Music]
you do Elden ring lore videos and think
the story isn't great I don't think it
isn't great I think it's extremely
confusing on purpose which
I don't like
I think a lot of people think that
it's not like confusing because it's
good
you know
it's confusing because they purposely
made it that way does that make sense
Esther thank you for the five months
time does fly very true
very true
that's from soft's Mo I don't I I don't
like Sakura wasn't confusing at all
um bloodborne was confusing at first
until DLC that's true
um
Dark Souls
[Music]
somewhat but it's not as confusing as
Elden ring
Elden ring is easily like we have so
many holes to fill we don't even know
where to start you know what I'm saying
where it's like with dark souls we had
some questions but bloodborne we had
some questions
uh that were answered in DLC
but with Alden ring I don't even know
where to begin on the things that I'm
confusing
it said like rain I got you
waiting for the Post raging how
how great Elden ring is complete with an
insulting remark
true
I'm fighting ishin listening to this and
I've been banging my head on Roblox
Ian man uh ishin's insane
like yeah good luck good luck mate
what up bizarre how are you
I didn't like Sakura because there was
no custom character creator
I mean it was a different game than what
they usually do it wasn't an RPG
so I didn't expect to have a character
creator and a non-rpg
is this the music in this area
because it's nice
Elder ring has much more complex lore it
had two people working on the story
instead of just Miyazaki
I mean I'm sure more people worked on
the story of Dark Souls and bloodborne
besides Miyazaki but you you mean like
main people yeah that's true
Elder ring isn't going to get DLC which
sucks
um
I'd be surprised if we got DLC this year
I think it would be the worst business
decision ever
to not have DLC for Elden ring
um but we know from software like
sometimes they don't give a [ __ ] about
what makes them money
you know
maybe they want Elden ring to just be
exactly what it is and we're all
confused all the time and that's just
what we get
I don't think sekiro counts as a soul it
wasn't made by Miyazaki is that true was
it not made by Miyazaki
I'm just listening to music right now to
be honest
let me turn my fan on
already hot
I'm pretty sure Miyazaki did make sakiro
um it's definitely a souls-like game so
I it's it's a Souls game for sure
all right
no more debates oh God
I gotta get my eyes adjusted
the 30 frames
oh my eyes are struggling right now bro
you guys hear everything are we good
I had to plug it I plugged in my PS5
like
literally five minutes ago
I don't like these sounds that I'm
hearing
I don't remember this area having these
creepy sound effects
wind boners
let's try the sneaker nope
nope
nope nope nope
yeah I remember you guys made me go here
last time we did this and this area is
not easy
barbarians of the Badlands was fake
supposedly
supposedly fake that came out months ago
God damn this game has such a [ __ ]
vibe
hello
please leave me
don't tell me please
oh please take off
damn
please leave me be okay I'm not gonna
[ __ ] with her
you're helping for mikola content
I mean we could get anything who knows
what it is
but I don't fully disagree with people
who say that Elden Rings lore is
not their favorite
you know
look at this guy
merciful Gods please
can I go down
no I can only go up
okay let's go this way
okay maybe I should not have done that
oh God
holy [ __ ]
77 de silly and 700. oh God here we go
777 thank you Andrew how are you
177 sextillions
777 quintillion 777 quadrillion 777
trillion 7 777 billion seven hundred
seven seven seven seven seven seven
seven seven seven seven seven seven
hundred
why did he say it's so slow that was
creepy
good morning man
thank you Andrew
someone goes bloodborne is ass
man
great debate bro
I think you're right just based on your
your proof
is a very lucky number
I don't think I want to go back here
[Music]
I know fighting these guys are I don't
like fighting these guys
could just run away
but they like grab and [ __ ] I'm gonna go
down here
if George R Martin is involved we're
never gonna get DLC good point
should have been The Voice
said hello
absolutely cream myself love this type
of lovecraftian story building me too
dude it's it's a Vibe for sure
bullets
I'm telling you guys I should have been
the voice actor
for a lot of characters
I already did that
poison knives
if you talk to the girl while wearing
Church Garb she will actually talk to
you really
I don't think I have church clothes
though
if I find some we'll go back
I'm gonna run Chad
oh wait
we got a we got a boss here don't we yes
we do
what's this
oh yeah I can have a a dude come and
help me
another Bell just like Elden ring
I love it
black hood is a part of church Garb oh
okay
nice
let's see what we got
I think Elden ring is a good story but
you have to be a person that likes that
type of story if you simplify it you are
compelled to become Eldon Lord just as
the roon bearers and the Lords before
you no I agree it can be trying to
understand Elden ring and everything
about it I think is what frustrates
people
um but when you boil it down to what
it's actually about that's pretty much
what it is
you're kind of like you are compelled to
be Elden Lord just from like the opening
thing to
go and do that thing like my entire
first playthrough and I'm sure with all
of you guys as well it was pretty much
like I'm gonna be Elden Lord I want to
be the Elden Lord [ __ ] yeah that sounds
lit and then I just did it which has to
be the underlying narrative that
Miyazaki and George R Martin was going
for was like why are we just following
like what looks cool or what people tell
us that we should go do you know like
why did we just
follow the light the entire time and a
lot of people didn't but most people I
would say did so thank you for the ten
dollars AMV and I I that's a I agree
with you completely
do I have any fires doesn't this guy
like
he's weak against fire or something
right I don't know I don't remember this
is gonna suck I'm definitely gonna die
but let's get it
ow that hurt
oh god
um
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
I do not remember how to fight him
[Applause]
house
so wow
[Music]
God he's so cool
nice get his face
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
that actually just insta killed me dude
um I don't know about you guys the game
is loud as balls for me
holy [ __ ]
I have to turn down my headphones dude
oh my God
go downstairs go downstairs
that was a great first try it I think if
we have fire we're good
we go back let me go back here
[Music]
I'll turn it down
cheese grilled cheese grilled cheese
grilled cheese grilled cheese grilled
cheese grilled cheese grilled cheese
okay here we go so music I say we have
it at 10 at all times right guys just
kidding how about an eight we're gonna
turn these down
just turn the sound effects down they're
so loud
do I have any poppy boys
I do
excellent
why can't I use multiple when I have oh
it's just a seven I get it
thank you Andrew for the grilled cheese
man I appreciate it
[Music]
I appreciate it
do we have any fire
paper
oh cocktails might be good fire paper is
a lot holy piss
holy
[ __ ] I don't think we need it let's see
if we can upgrade
cheese
I don't think we need it
because we almost got him there
hey we upgraded once we need some more
twin blades we're good
oh we're here now
okay
you take more damage you get hit during
a Dodge right
yeah I don't think it's worth it either
I know he's weak to it
I used to speedrun this game like four
or five years ago
holy [ __ ] what the hell is that the Moon
but I forget
how to like
get him to die there
no grabbing
no grabbing please
okay let's try that again
uh I have no idea how far we are in the
game not not super far
let's try that again
on calm dungeon
a lot of people don't like those
dungeons do they
you get more blood Echoes with the moon
Rune do I have to equip it
all right let's go brother
oh okay
ow
really
[Music]
okay
no why oh
okay
[Music]
my man spam that [ __ ]
which he still had a PS5 so you could
play it my PS5 broke and I got lucky
enough to get a PS or my PS4 broke and
I'm lucky enough to get a PS5
foreign
oh God gamerwolf calm down holy [ __ ]
Jesus
[Music]
ugh
I do not I don't know
no
grab
foreign
I did not realize how abruptly the Music
Stops there
your PS3 broke well that makes sense
that's like a 15 year old console or
whatever
you can buy PS5 straight from
PlayStation Now
can you
put you
upgraded my Xbox here recently I'm on
the hunt for PS5 now it might be a while
before I can find and afford one though
I hope you do
I feel like lock off is the play
for sure
okay buddy
[Music]
there we go
foreign
why is he spamming that
[Music]
my God
[Music]
I can't tell what he's doing bro
you do your thing
[Music]
I'm scared of him doing the thing that
insta kills me
can I stab him in the face here I don't
think so
[Music]
actually I can go at him right now
foreign
[Music]
leave me alone leave me alone
[Music]
is he throwing these at me kind of looks
like it
[Music]
okay
[Music]
I'm so scared of getting interested dude
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
no come on man
the [ __ ] insta kill
it's so hard
oh JoJo thank you for becoming a tarnish
welcome good to have you
man this thing just
man
kills me so quickly
well welcome JoJo good to have you no I
don't have fire paper and it's really
expensive
two times playback speed to catch up I
love that nice
yeah the sound design is really good
overwhelming in my ear right now
streaming this game is not easy
okay let's go again
I love the abrupt cut off as soon as I
get in this tunnel
not at all what I wanted to do there I
pulled an Elden ring and pressed y
and gamerwolf coming in here with
opinions I like it
somewhat
except the you only have three good
videos and flout I don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about with that
foreign
[Music]
no come on man
okay if I get behind him I think I'm
okay when he does that
[Music]
the AOE doesn't stretch very far behind
him
[Music]
the tail count is a limb
probably not
[Music]
no swing
that's not good okay
[Music]
sorry to tell what's Happening Here
[Music]
I I can't see
[Music]
I don't know what like I I can't follow
him
he's so all over the place
I Koshi thank you I apologize for that
your vids are great why'd you say it
then you forehead
hi Gastly how are you
I don't know where vati ER came out
uh vatis made some of the best Elden
Ring videos
they're incredible
we gonna flatten it Platinum it we're
gonna do everything we can
that's for sure
okay I got it I really gotta relearn
this fight I'm slowly doing it but it's
not easy
fight is hard
resonates with another
[Applause]
yeah behind him seems okay there
[ __ ]
couldn't get behind him it's kind of
like malachas in his one attack they
gotta get behind
let's go
and
and that's dead all right sick
[Music]
yeah when you summon does it buff the
boss
so I feel like I'm doing absolutely no
damage unless we knock him over which is
mainly how this game works actually
foreign
dungeons we could check it out
oh God
what leave me alone
I don't have fire paper
it's too expensive
now that I'm here without it I'm gonna
do it without it
Malachi's starving brother kinda
yeah my blood vials are getting low
trying to get this done in like the next
two fights at least so we don't have to
go and farm but that's that'd be okay
yeah the deaths and death move you know
what I'm talking about
and Dodge through his AOE
so if I dodge at the right time I won't
get hit by the AOE
[Applause]
all right
probably a tough time huh
it's so hard to tell where his hitbox is
[Music]
you're right
[Music]
because I think I did Dodge that right
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
get up in there
[Music]
come here
[Music]
please don't kill me
[Music]
please don't kill me
[Music]
stop throwing lasers at me
[Music]
scared
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
how am I not hitting him I'm inside him
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
let's go spark Hunter badge
lit
zero blood Echoes retrieved
hell yeah
yup Pro gamer Pro Gamer indeed
obviously
that is a cool boss if we had fire paper
we would have beat him like five tries
earlier but
you just go for the limbs man that's
pretty much it
see I got no Poppy boys
I think like that doesn't even lead to
anything right
it's like a not a shortcut
it leads to
old yharnam if I remember
open the bug door in the boss room the
big door yeah I know
I know I know
um I feel like more health will be nice
a little more endurance
farewell Good Hunter bye Mommy
oh I can't go directly is it here
graveyard of the dark Beast
yeah it just goes back to Old yharnam so
I don't think it actually like helps us
hundreds of hours appears from software
Bliss I love this game too man I think I
have like five
no I'd say I have more than 500 hours in
this game
but I haven't played it in like four
years
please remaster this game please
give us 60 frames per second please
is this lead anywhere significant
we're just back here okay
do a kick flip
there you go oh hello
you a bad man nope you're a dead man
yeah I mean yeah it looks absolutely
gorgeous but imagine like
2022 graphics
Elden ring graphics
be freaking insane
master pass on gearman
um I would smash his OST
well it wouldn't matter if you had a PC
because you can't play it on PC it's
only on PlayStation
[Music]
the moon it's Ronnie
where's my doll hello
where'd she go
the Moon is close
it will be a long hunt tonight
and threatened to crush your spirits
shake a holy chalice
every Hunter before you as
a holy chalice will reveal the Tomb of
the Gods
where Hunters partake in communion
okay
there you are
you respecting Welcome Home Good Hunter
what is it you desire guys could you
date a girl who's this much taller than
you Hunters have told me about the
church
about the gods and their love
but to the gods love their Christmas
he's like a viking woman
I am a doll created by you humans
would you ever seem to love me
sure of course
I do love you
isn't that how you've made the taller
the better to hold me
I love it I love it
no I don't need that
bye Mommy
all right where did these go second
ritual altar
chaos dungeon oh these are the Chalice
dungeons huh oh God
okay we're gonna do that later
Viking actually averaged about five foot
seven
damn I'm five foot nine so I'm bigger
than a Viking
let's go I think we have to go here and
then go outside
[Music]
to death last night let's go Drew
oh
did I say your name right
Anna Lloyd gold
the only game I've played is Elden Rings
should I play the games before the
answer to that is yes
why do you like him man
do I hear a pig
a piggy
what up dog
that's a dead pig
whoops not what I want to do good thing
I got two back
Behold a pale blood sky
[Music]
this looks dark to me
music is louder the closer you get
[Music]
you're right
[Music]
this game is so [ __ ] cool
foreign
[Music]
how's your experience as a content
creator streaming on YouTube Compared to
Twitch
um well I don't know if you guys have
followed the drama on Twitch right now
but I'm glad I'm on YouTube
I'll say that
um oh I can just grab it
looks pretty cool
um
I think the chat
on YouTube the people that are actually
here are better than the people on
Twitch like just chat wise I I've had a
better experience
I know chat in general isn't as good on
YouTube as it is on Twitch like the
experience of chat
um but we're kind of making our own type
of
culture with that
ourselves
so it's it'll just take time but
[Music]
um Quality on streaming on YouTube is
way better than than twitch
God damn it's so loud
um the quality is obviously better here
like I can stream in 1440p 60 frames per
second and you know it looks great
whereas on twitch sometimes it just
looks [ __ ] awful
um you guys have skippable ads as well
that must be a much better experience
whereas on Twitch you could get like
[ __ ]
20 ads in a row and or like seven or six
or whatever and you can't skip them and
what do you do leave the website leave
that stream
um I personally like the experience on
YouTube much more
you can yeah there's a better playback
system on YouTube as well
where you can go back and see what
happened
it's very true
oops
it's over boys we got dogs on us
never mind
oh God it's over
it's over
thank you
it's over voice
and I streamed on Twitch for four years
just uh I guess prove what I'm talking
about
[Music]
why are there so many dogs bro
[Music]
my health
[Music]
dude I can't even hear myself think
right now holy [ __ ]
it's so loud I love it
oh
no no no I don't fight those guys
uh-uh
three
blood vials old paper
so what was I talking about I've had a
much better experience on YouTube the
Truffle extensions makes YouTube chat
look good at least
um yeah I have to I signed up for it I
haven't been like you have to be on a
waitlist to even get it now so we'll see
if we can get that later
I see ads on Twitch at all and I leave
same
[Music]
I'm scared
okay I don't know what you just said
Johnny but
it's all blocked out
imagine if Final Fantasy 8 intro theme
just started playing right here dude I'm
cool with this music hitting me
this music slaps
this music goes hard as balls
you know what I mean
nice I think we can upgrade with that
is it worth playing this game after
Eldon ring
oh yeah
a thousand percent
I think this game is better than Elden
ring that tells you anything about how I
feel about it okay we can definitely go
upgrade
I could just walk around in this game
and listen to the music all day dude
um I think the one to just finish what
we were talking about I think the one
thing that YouTube is missing and you
can agree or disagree with me on this is
the culture of live streaming because
most people go to YouTube for the
um longer videos
like 10 to 20 minutes usually
um and they're not used to going to
YouTube for a live streaming experience
but I think more people that come from
twitch to YouTube will realize that this
is actually a better experience for the
viewer
um and then they will start funneling
over here instead of twitch
and then it'll bring that culture with
it as well
you know what I'm saying
so I'd like to be here at the beginning
okay what can I slap on this daddy
nope we definitely like that more okay
we don't have that many of us cool
maybe overstepping but I can lead you to
a good source of blood vials no I'm good
Samantha
I know what I'm doing in this game for
the most part
yeah I enjoy watching streams and
obviously videos on YouTube much more
uh than twitch
lower quality
on Twitch and
uh I just get bombarded with ads all the
time so
yeah it's a good idea nuni I think they
are gonna do that
you get gemstones and dungeons
oh yeah I pretty much just archive my
streams as well
into a playlist
did I upgrade
I think I only looked at gems
[Music]
my brain's all over the place I did I
did I did what am I looking for though
uh eight twin blood shards got it
what up blush how are you
have any poppy boys
yep
I did upgrade
I did I did Welcome Home what is it you
very well let me stand
hey
how much does skill physical defense and
it brings us up a tad bit
ah strength is better
[Music]
what up D
uh the big
the big plus for streams on this
platform yep I agree I agree
helden ring is literally Dark Souls 4.
um
it's like four five and six
to be honest
it's my game of the year 2015.
didn't this game win game of the year
scales visceral attacks
Witcher 3 beat this game
I did like the Witcher 3 a good amount
Witcher 3 is a good game
I don't know how I feel about this
my health back
let's see how bad this actually is
[Music]
those guys just scare the [ __ ] out of me
to be blatantly honest with you I don't
like fighting them at all
goodness yes
oh God
followed me oh no
whoa
[Music]
now it's all muffled
[Applause]
you're gonna give me Pebbles aren't they
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah I've been here okay cool
like tactically just another shortcut
yeah I personally didn't like
I would have voted for bloodborne over
Witcher 3 for Game of the Year
obviously
but Witcher 3 had a lot of it's a good
game
I don't think we can really argue that
it's not a good game
leave me be
do I have to like come back here later
is there like nowhere else to go here
yeah because that's not open
I don't think I can open it
a closed off area for now
we'll come back later then
parl was through the door you opened I
already fought parl what
what what
what what what what what what
mikolash
oh God I remember that fight
not not my favorite fight in the game
I'll tell you that welcome
did I just get this many and
you're out here leveling right now okay
farewell
um okay I know where to go now I know
where to go
we need to go to Cathedral Ward and then
I go up and to the left
yeah we killed Paul
oh we could have talked to the girl in
the church
that is true
okay
this is pretty much the weapon I'm gonna
use for my build I like this weapon
yep we gotta have the we gotta have the
gimmick bosses boys
it's just a part of the culture
yeah it's PlayStation exclusive yep yep
leave me alone leave me
oh I could have just gone to this
Lantern up here
it's okay we chilling
now we randomly go out in the woods
reminds me of Dark Souls 3.
sounds like you [ __ ] up D
damn I love how we just like
it just shoots you out here
I mean I run the other way when I see
that
I really do
red
oh [ __ ]
to the gate
oh it's opening I didn't get the
animation though please
no [ __ ]
I just I just clipped out of an
animation to open the door what the [ __ ]
uh what the heck okay I know where to go
now at least
um yeah I'm gonna go to the church
I need to spend insight
where do I spend that at
I don't remember is it here
I don't remember where to spend it
a messenger
you've escaped this Dreadful Hunter's
dream halt the source of the spreading
scourge of beasts lest the night carry
on forever why is that hidden in a
[ __ ] corner
such good information oh
workshops will require for the task is
missing
all right
storage
walk into cabin door on the left
okay thank you oh we got fire paper baby
do we even need this at this point like
is fire paper like still good
I'm up by five
[ __ ] it
um
uh that's fine
and then I can use madman's knowledge to
get more right
is that how that works
[Music]
okay I think the grand Cathedral
Church of the Good chalice
wait where Where Do We Fight vicar vicar
[Music]
just need to bold Hunter's Mark out of
the witch's fight first time because
each boss gives you inside spend all
Insight the witch boss won't spawn any
ads at zero
Korean
this stream see wait this seems like a
perfect game to stream during October
since it's spooky
we play some horror games as well
you know what I really want to stream
that I think would be a lot of fun is um
have you guys heard of them
is it Mortuary
Mortuary assistant
that could be really fun
hello
I love horror games oh
I'm lost
there we go
Resident Evil 2. I haven't played the
Resident Evils
I don't know why I've never been
interested in it
what's the hottest boss in the series
the hottest I have no idea
maybe this is why you're a maidenless
dirty foul tarnished
why do these dogs look so scary man
the answer is Gwendolyn
man dude
Fame on all of you
Lantern Lantern Lantern
it's off the [ __ ] out of here mate
father gascoigne is the hottest
you do got that breath
what does this remind you of
foreign
[Music]
neighborhood yeah
stop kidding me now
what is this thing
bloodshot eyeball what is that I don't
remember what that is at all
exactly what I was thinking
crazy ladies
hello what do you have on your uh blade
there lady
nice that's upgrade material right there
eyeballs used for the Chalice Dunes okay
I've literally never used the Chalice
dungeons so
[Music]
well [ __ ] you too [ __ ]
God damn that was scary
what the hell is that
[Laughter]
seemed a little out of left field
it's an actual ladder no okay
everyone's like same honestly that's how
I feel right
that's how the world is making me feel
lately just
like no thanks I'm good go away
you got a big stick
you're dead
stop it
a certified FW moment
I might make that into a short boys
apparently uh YouTubers gotta start
pushing shorts
because YouTube's like we love shorts
now
Northstar poggers
all right guys
totally not trying to take tick tock's
market share
obviously
whoa whoa whoa whoa big rock boy out of
nowhere
I can't see because you're so dummy
thick
Geeks
khakis or baller shorts
that's a very interesting question
can I wear no shorts
is that an answer
lady
do you plan on doing more lorevids of
other Souls games I don't know why I
would
because it's been done already
you know I don't think there's like any
interest in me talking about what other
people have already talked about you
know
I mean apparently if you have successful
shorts like people subscribe
and now they're making it so that you
can actually get paid
for shorts which is pretty cool
foreign
I mean if that wasn't the case then
nobody would do it
do Modern Warfare 2 lore I played the
beta all weekend did anybody else
it's pretty good
I enjoy it
there's a friendly Crow
well that friendly chloro is dead
yo yo yo yo
lady put it out
Tick Tock is mid I think uh yeah I don't
really like Tick-Tock either
do you guys watch shorts it's out of
curiosity
I've seen a couple of you say yes
or that you like them
saw that coming
whoa
this is a horror game like a thousand
percent this game is a literal horror
game it's not even a Souls game it's a
it's a horror game yes when I'm bored
yes sometimes sometimes I can't stop
watching them they're addicting
wow really I don't watch shorts at all
that's crazy okay
I mean I guess that's why they're
pushing them
what up Jay
wait I need you I need you Dad actually
you
I'm coming
nice
I have void shorts I don't watch videos
on my phone and they look weird on my
laptop that makes sense
shorts makes my mind feel numb
occasionally just not a fan of its UI
yet some interesting Ones based on your
watch History
random Sports vids uh you're asking
I don't watch shorts at all
a lot of shorts pushes big creators
I mean I saw
um
not a well okay so somebody I know who
was in the rocket League scene with me
they switched to Minecraft and they had
zero subscribers on their YouTube
channel right and they started doing
Minecraft Shorts
let's see what that guy is at now uh
subscriber wise
because
it's gonna blow your mind like guess he
was at zero subscribers at the beginning
of the year what do you guys think he's
at now only doing Minecraft Shorts
I can even remember his name I know it
starts with an m
M [ __ ] I don't remember
Maples Maples that's what it is
okay y'all are way off
way off bro
yeah guys click like on the stream he is
at
1.52 million
subscribers
use that zero at the beginning of the
year
1.52 million subscribers
he only makes shorts
for the most part he does have some
longer videos
but all of his shorts get millions of
views
it absolutely unbelievable
I want to make shorts if you guys didn't
know I have a history of making short
content on Tick Tock
um I made tip videos for Rocket league
on Tick Tock and I got 200 230 000
followers from that however Tick Tock is
butt cheeks so I wish I did it through
shorts but
I don't know what I would make sure it's
on with
Souls content you know
hello
hey thanks Cole
do you know did you see that coal that
Maples has 1.5 million subscribers on
YouTube now for making shorts
and then now his longer videos that he
they're like eight minutes long will get
like 200 000 views each
Elden ring tips and tricks
yeah same Cole it's really cool to hear
though I'm I'm proud of them because I
know he was grinding
yeah I mean YouTube is just pushing
shorts like no other so it's pretty
clear
you guys see the soccer game that was
streamed the other day
was that yesterday or the day before I
don't know
they had like two million viewers on
their stream
or more
you're dead
another blondes to Bloodstone chart I
love that why do you need to make new
content when you can take existing
videos and make them shorts
do you think that's okay to do like
would people get mad about that because
I'd do that in a millisecond
S no you won't
you're dead
yeah that or whatever you guys call it
football soccer
yeah yeah
oh God
oh God
not everyone's seen it
eldering the wall shorts on my feed the
wall
a lot of shorts based on stream
highlights shorts are good but need to
topic specific I guess
absolutely
okay
I could do that
best shorts YouTuber is you I don't make
shorts
go back in your footage and boom
countless moments you could make into
shorts I mean think of how many videos
have I made
on Elden ring actually
realistically not that many
uh but I could break them down
that's very very possible
foreign
Souls boss radon radon will always be my
favorite boss ever
oh then it will be me well thank you
start recording I mean these are all
recorded
well they're on my channel
that hurt my soul like my ego just got
hurt right there
are you blocking my guy
blocking me on Twitter there we go
is AGT Jake's shorts not you
um I have a channel that I haven't
started
called AGT Jake Shorts
it's called Clips or something
wait is there somebody making clips of
my [ __ ]
wait wait wait wait wait
it's called Clips not shorts what are
you talking about
hold on a minute
okay good that is me
oh I already have a channel that I
forgot about
oh
okay it's me guys it's me it's me
I have my best one has 1.4 000 views and
it's me playing Apex
nope I got a Minecraft one I totally
forgot about this channel what the [ __ ]
I forgot I had one
wow interesting all right have a good
one Drew
Drew
yes that's me I just didn't think anyone
knew about it
you kidding me
but I would post shorts onto this
channel don't you think
since they're getting pushed
I I do make too many channels Cole this
is true I'm trying to fix all this stuff
okay
oh piss
my pairing timing is really good don't
you think
you're bad
[Music]
actually trash
it has your face dude I've shown so many
of my face
everywhere
just sometimes I don't like using camera
like today you think I showered today
you're wrong
that's why I look gross
so no camera
oh god oh
this is a vibe
let's make it only fans you guys want to
see me naked
where did you come from sir
Harry a hug
it's just like my mom
JK
foreign
you guys don't want to see me naked bro
kidding me
come on
I don't think I'm bad looking or
anything but I'm not only fans good
looking
no Insight Strat I don't know if that's
a strat but I'm out here doing it
like I feel like only fans people are
just insanely good looking right
I think I'm good looking for a normal
guy
if I was going to make a second Channel
it would be for golf content it actually
would I have no idea how to record golf
though it seems extremely hard
foreign
okay where am I
play The Witch boss with zero insight
and she won't spawn ads isn't she isn't
she ridiculously easy regardless oh yep
I remember
I remember where you at there you are
this fight's ridiculously easy anyway
it's okay
play with the inside hello
are there two of them
where are you going buddy kind of bad at
your job
where you at
foreign
w
[Music]
ow
good music though yeah
[Music]
where is she
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
oh there you are
let me be
I see you
I see you
[Applause]
[Music]
he fell
[Applause]
man this boss is kind of poo poo hello
[Music]
the music though
oh
he spawn he's over there in the corner
I got this oh there you are
oh that's not the right one
I swear I saw something
oh
my God
[Applause]
what the titties
what the titties man
now I get it I really only thought there
was one even though you told me there
was two
I'm a little dumb you didn't already
know that
[Music]
wish I had that emote really easy way to
fix that problem
hello
[Applause]
there you are
[Music]
get her out of there wait the other
one's alive again now
oh yeah [ __ ] you
she legit just slapped me
[Applause]
[Music]
she [ __ ] slapped me dude
[Music]
[Music]
I see you
I'm dumb
thank you
[Music]
where where
me out
you just in the middle of the room you
[ __ ]
[Applause]
bro gamer
that was a really hard boss fight guys
a lot of effort went into that one
GG's in the chat
I'm a poor student now I'll gladly
become a member once I have stable
income again
I like that plan
hopefully there's still uh it's still
possible to get subs
sometimes that goes away for some reason
but you never know who's generous
I think you have to be on
desktop to even do it
unfortunately
upgrade
there's a workshop tool all right bed
I'm going back
make that little moment a short
what little moment
[Music]
which is abode
I think lady Maria would [ __ ] Melania up
that'd be a good ass fight no cap
yeah the runes down here right
the church Garb girl okay
dude look how cool this looks
with the lighting
an old Hunter
who did not make it
Rune Workshop tool thank you
what up femi
thank you
guys who would win in a fight sister
Frida Melania or lady Maria
that would be a fight of oh God that
would just be insane
um we're gonna do as much as we can
Brandon yeah
but I'm not like uh making myself do
anything you know
there you are welcome home what is it
very well let me
is it Melania a literal God
I mean Aspen gold calls himself a
literal God does that make him a literal
God
yes
yes it does
I've seen videos of lady Maria defeating
sister Frida really
um
would would sister Frida get all three
of her or her uh
phases
lady butterfly
nah lady butterfly gets absolutely
annihilated into next week sorry to say
absolutely annihilated
where
there was definitely more places to go
right than where I was
like how it says above ground
waterfowl is an instant GG
I think you're right
okay let me uh let me go check the girl
so you're saying that I can wear uh this
black hood
and that would be birchware
could I wear like foreign garb
black gloves
foreign trousers
like would this be good to talk to her
oh inside shop and buy gas coins armor
gotcha but there was nothing I didn't
check everything
okay because I want to get that lore
I like lore
this game is like depression and
existential dread the game I love it no
kidding dude
it's great isn't it
oh I can buy oh [ __ ] okay that's cool
do I have to buy all of it
I would assume
hmm lore
only chest
all right I'll believe you just chest
I'll wear the black hood
oh God look at this bod [ __ ] yeah dude
okay uh gascoigne
Hunter
I'm kind of sick drip no cap
all right now we gotta go back
through the screaming lady
the crying lady
inside shop has boss and hostile NPC
armor
okay I'm glad you guys are here because
I didn't know any of this [ __ ]
I grabbed the best armor
which was uh
what the whatever the [ __ ] it's called
Hunter's garb
where's she at down here
hello
Papi Chulo
this horrible dream
that's scary
oh I made her cry [ __ ]
sorry
stop crying I'm sorry
that's me
what do you say
you're welcome
my relief
you can take this at least
thank you I I needed that clearly
oh thank you so much dear God
is she talking specifically to Father
guest going there or just like the
attire I'm wearing just makes her you
know in general
thank you so much
I received on the street
by the Hawking brute in the cathedral
Ward and locked up here
they've been taken away
oh god I've heard moans echoing in the
distance ever since
[Music]
that sounds scary
damn right it is
hi
that isn't my place to ask but
do you know somewhere that might oh go
to the church
yeah go to the church oh thank you so
much
I'll set out as soon as I can
I pray for Success on your hunt yeah
this voice acting is really good
breaking the fourth wall and addressing
me well I'm I am not a part of the
church I'll tell you that I'll set out
as soon as I can I pray for sick kind
Hunter okay hopefully you'll stop crying
in the church
they trust the church I wouldn't trust
the church I wouldn't trust the church
at all
oof
I would not trust the church at all
you guys ever seen the movie spotlight
it's one of my favorite movies ever
let's go hunter hat
I don't like this gas going but looks
cool you like this drip
drip trip
wait how does a top hat look with this
oh
yes dude
I'll talk to Ariana
I'd love to talk to Ariana Grande
she's my favorite
um
so you want me to go here Cathedral Ward
wait didn't I tell her to go here
no no
I mean the one from the I know I'm
kidding
don't get Ariana's blood while the nun
is in the church otherwise she'll kill
her
oh we got drama in the church
drama
drama
oh the hunter yo thank you
to that only woman you told her about
this place right
I did she don't offer me much in a way a
conversation but still
I'd rather see her alive anywhere
Triumph I love this guy if you find any
sane survivors well
send him a lot no word and chuckle will
ya
Jesus okay yeah where is she you even
here
lady
there you are hello
oh Brave I like how she stood up when I
walked by
I feel very respected thank you very
much
you're welcome
the town is in disarray but there are
still people here
together we await the help of
I don't think so Samantha
I came to express my gratitude to you
the only thing that I can offer
is my own lowly blood oh it's suffice
huh
um do I want this that seems really
sketch
and a good way to spread AIDS
it's pretty good
she should be around the corner she
doesn't deserve you I know I am pretty
great
she doesn't have AIDS
good okay she gave me no no no no no
hold on I'll I'll be I'll be back I'll
be back where is she around the corner
yeah actually around the corner
oh we still got this
Uber over here
[Applause]
exiting the tomb go left
oh I love her
perfect timing
I must sworn you not to go near the tomb
below urgent Chapel in the cathedral
Ward
Henrik
an old Hunter
has gone mad
and he's my mark okay we don't we do not
touch that guy guys
nope
she has made that very clear Don't Go
Near the tomb below urgent Chapel in the
cathedral Ward
I have business there first
okay is she nuts
I didn't like that little chuckle at the
end
that little chuckle uh not I'm not okay
with that
she say below
that goes up
when I've already been there is she
talking about the dude that shoots at
you in uh the old old area
I'm getting her blood
huh
have you written
yes of course
coming close
now
take my blood this is so weird
blood of Adela
okay
Brave Hunter
please give me a little more time
there are others in need of My Blood
so what did I just do
foreign
delicious
excellent
come here for the bloodborne ring
we're shirtless okay
oh what up coach how you doing man
yeah we back we back
go to a doctor
I don't know
wait why wouldn't I use the lamp I'm
trying to go somewhere else
oh she's dead isn't she
oh we're taking a nap over here
[Music]
oh
[Music]
he's tired
oh that's true I could have
you said it's by gascoigne I don't want
to wake her up
[Music]
yeah yeah
aha not functioning but we do have to go
backwards because somebody's there
yeah I'm on PS5
the doll is modeled after Maria
lady Maria in the game it's pretty cool
how we doing over here still alive okay
cool we're gonna go backwards
as the game changed months since he used
to speedrun
doesn't look like it
but not speed running in all that time
like usually when you're speed running
you go down one
you have one route that you focus trying
to master and you don't know all the
other things about it you know or about
the game
all right what's going on out here
holy [ __ ]
that scared the piss out of me
I don't want to kill him I want the
other lady to kill him
oh you're here perfect
can I help
ouch
am I allowed to help chat
shoots me back
when she have died without my help
there we go
why did she look at me so menacingly
air
where you going
oh God
that wasn't necessary of you but you
have my thanks you're welcome we made it
with our lives
you're not bad at all
you must have killed gascon as well then
I did
he was falling apart I'm sure it had to
be done
but try to keep your hands clean
a hunter should hunt beasts
leave the hunting of hunters to me
okay my trust in this girl is all the
way gone it's gone try to keep your hand
lay the hunt
well you hear that right there that
little chuckle yeah anyone in real life
who talks to you like that chat
Don't Go Near him
that's a big note for me chief
so she would die if I didn't help and
then if I wasn't here I'd become her
enemy interest
leave the haunting of hunters to me
she's actually saying oh I don't know
about that
are any of us saying anymore
am I getting too deep with that question
probably
My Level maybe welcome what how was your
nap very well
endurance
farewell good I mean yeah compared to
everyone else in the game I'm sure she's
quite sane
absolutely
I just don't trust her
which we shouldn't trust anybody
not in this world okay wasn't there
another way for me to go here
or does this area only lead to the witch
I swear there's more to do over here
now we got the crazy ladies
but I unlocked this over here didn't I
did
bye bye
didn't you guys say there was like a
nice Crow
yeah we beat Amelia
there's more to do after the witch but
only if you have a specific item that's
right
wait did I get the item I needed from
vicar
the car
okay this is where I went before
Oh great excellent
he fell too
oh this Falls
I get in the next area
that's a short every I can't just like
actually
from what I've seen
uh
you just Spam shorts and it works
you hear that
there's a path near the dogs at the
beginning of this area
but not over here
okay
go back
there
I'm having a good time with this
there we go
hey a bot let's go
get out of here
see I don't know how to like what shorts
are would be good or not like maybe it
doesn't [ __ ] matter dude
you know
foreign
[Music]
cleared this area out
Joy
joy joy joy
that is definitely a thing they need to
fix on YouTube streaming is the Bots
dude
Bots are very annoying
whoa whoa whoa
like a rhino
ow that hurt
foreign
I want to get truffle so that we can do
like predictions and chat and stuff that
would be fun
and then you guys can earn Channel
points just by watching that is
definitely a good feature of twitch
for sure
but I have to I'm on a waiting list for
truffle
okay
yeah I know that f
or femi
sometimes I do use sometimes I don't
[Music]
um I don't think so
not sure
like two hours Vincent
so this is where I went to go to the the
witches
is there another path over here
I love the vibe this is so cool
yeah imagine this game full rendered PC
graphics
I think I'd poop my pants
what do you think has the best story and
lore bloodborne a thousand percent
this game has the best lore overall
we need bloodborne too before bloodborne
three my guy
it's a special path in the Forbidden
Woods which gets you an item to go
somewhere from Emily Turner Lane
okay
this guy just hit me with some Madness
seems kind of odd
I have no idea who Alfred is
why is the belt shiny
what is happening up here
God damn this game is so [ __ ] sick
okay
come back here after ROM gotcha gotcha
why do you keep asking that femi what
are you saying
wait for me to go this way
can't really rest
oh
hi Mabel how are you
there are a bunch of notes that say that
oh
oh my ass who are you
no no no
stop this
what is happening
oh I don't like this at all nope
nope nope
nope
nope
you got a blunderbuss [ __ ] you
why do you keep backing up
why are you being a Weenie Hut Junior
girl huh
we need a junior crew
keep blunderbussing me
I feel like I should just not deal with
this this is kind of weird
she has a gun in that thing
in her weapon
what is happening here
all right
okay
just kept backing up it was so annoying
oh how far away am I gonna be
oh piss all right let's go back
you're making me want to get this one I
recommend this game more than eldenry
I'm just I I am just a giant fan of this
game
do I want to go the direction I was
going
we're gonna go there anyway
I like sakuro too
kiro's a good game
okay I'll keep going that way
I might not fight them because that
seemed a bit ridiculous
I don't know what ridiculous means but
you know what I mean
I don't want all that knowledge right
now I'm good
exploring
I don't need to go farm knowledge
okay Brian stop telling me where to go
I'll tell you that right now my guy you
don't need to do that I will play the
game how I want to play it thank you
go down here
cool
where did they come from
I see
oh I wanted
do I get their weapons for killing them
thank you
so easy to kill
stop running
I feel like this is not where I want to
be
what's behind me
dude that Blunderbuss is so annoying
big glitch out
where am I
okay
no no
bye-bye
bye-bye
yeah you don't need to tell me where to
go to the next area man
okay where does this go
it's closed
oh God
um
okay
I yep
yep I remember that now
ah that scared the piss out
that's
okay
man
I got grabbed by one of these dudes
don't think I want to go that way yet
I remember right I got to do something
to make that door open
like I remember beating a boss
and I like end up there right
so
ow
elixir
[ __ ] together
how was that sound
okay
oh yeah I remember you
do not want to get grabbed
how would you know that was there I do
now
welcome to from software games where you
learn by dying
is this Alfred
yeah oh oh safe
now let's think up something to discuss
Johnny really wants the shorts seeks
your interest
oh oh hey we got all the lore here uh
healing church as you know the healing
church is The Fountainhead of blood
healing
well I'm a simple Hunter quite
unfamiliar with the ins and outs of the
institution
but I have heard that the holy medium of
blood healing is venerated in the main
Cathedral
and that counselors of the old church
reside in the high stratum of the
cathedral Ward
if you seek blood healing and the church
is willing you should pay them a visit
okay bergenworth bergenworth is an old
place of learning and the Tomb of the
Gods carved out below yharnam should be
familiar to every Hunter
well once a group of young bergenworth
scholars discovered a holy medium deep
within the tomb
this led to the founding of the healing
church and the establishment of blood
healing
in this sense everything sacred in young
my little dinos traced back to
bergenworth
but today the college lies deep within a
tangled wood abandoned and decrepit
and furthermore the healing church has
declared bergenworth forbidden ground
it's unclear how many of its Scholars
remain alive
but only they know the password that
allows Passage through the gate
is the password pickled ah there's
something I want to tell you
a bit of wisdom no I want to see what
happens
once a scholar betrayed his fellow as a
bergenworth and brought forbidden blood
back with him to cainhurst Castle
it was there that the first of the
inhuman vile Bloods was born
vile Bloods are fiendish creatures who
threaten the purity of the church's
blood healing
the ruler of the vile Bloods is still
alive today
so who honor my Master's wishes I search
for the path to cainhurst castle
hayneur's castle okay I bid you farewell
it has been a pleasure may the good
blood guide your way
yeah that voice acting is freaking nuts
he's so nice to listen to
okay
okay
can I open this
the password
fear the old blood
hello
already
[Laughter]
okay I see I'm going slightly insane
interesting
definitely heard someone there
can you guys like
are you guys able to clip stuff
is that a thing you guys oh this is how
you get to the Forbidden Woods okay
you have to go to cainer's Castle beat
legarus and meet the queen
yes you guys can clip
wanted to congratulate you on making all
the YouTube Subs man almost 100K I'm
proud of you oh thank you man I
appreciate that
wait you can
well [ __ ]
if you guys find something interesting
clip it I can make it into a short
I had no idea you guys could do that
that's cool
okay this is bad
never mind he's dead
flip it and ship it boys
hey
I really am gonna try out shorts I think
that's my next thing that I attempt if I
could like just make shorts and
dream
all the time I'd be a happy guy
I think um
I think interest in Eldon ring lore is
at an all-time low right now
and not just for me
but like most people are just like not
even looking at the game right now
what a short they would like just a
little quick thing
Brian calm down you're just a little
you're telling me too much
you gotta just let it happen you know
I'm sure it's there some shorts over
there
some shorts over there
I don't know until Elden ring DLC comes
out
then the game's just like I would say
Elder ring is at an all-time low right
now wouldn't you
oh yeah I totally remember this area
totally
[Music]
I don't know
can you play bloodborne on uh Remote
Play guys
okay this is where there's like traps
and stuff
foreign
not to you no I'm just saying like
player base and
I don't know viewage on YouTube for sure
is down heavy
you guys want to see something funny
oh wait I can't even show you it
can I
wait no I'm not on my PC so I can't
that's right I would pull something up
for you
and I put it in the chat maybe hold on
can I put a picture in chat
okay I'll just tell you to do something
go to a website called Google Trends and
type in eldenring
worldwide last 12 months
thing looks like a roller coaster oh
[ __ ]
remember when I was talking about traps
there it is
God damn it
I even know about the traps and I die to
the traps
no no bot
they're just spamming emotes like the
[ __ ] okay
uh this one has my Echoes
give me that back
die
get up in chart in February then slowly
went down
is this that that activates it that
little wooden pile It's gotta be
most people are fed up with elder ring
to a certain degree I I think so too I
think people are mostly burnt out on it
all
like think about it the game is massive
so like once you beat it once or maybe
twice you probably don't want to play it
again for a while
just because of how big the game is and
then
think of all of the lore that you have
to consume to understand literally
anything
it's kind of a tall task that I bet a
lot of people don't want to do
like they're kind of over it
you're like you know what this is too
confusing this is a lot I'll come back
later like when DLC comes out
which you know those numbers are gonna
go right back up to where they were
uh went out DLC is announced
this is the topper
this area is scary man
[Music]
foreign
made a clip called Jake is going crazy I
don't know how to view the clips you
guys have made
I'll figure it out I'll figure it out
thank you
I pressed the wrong button
man I think I am like really strong
or when vati does a new vid I mean okay
think about that
how many subscribers does vati video
have
it's got to be close to like three mil
right
he has a lot of subscribers
and then think about people who are just
trying to like go still like kind of
like myself with who are still trying to
go with the hype of the game to get
views on their videos
three seven yeah it's a lot
so he's going to get a lot of views
regardless just because he has so many
subscribers
whereas I'm just gonna say it for myself
we're still trying to go on the hype of
the game to get subscribers and views
and it's uh there's just not a lot of
hype behind it
so some of my subscribers are gonna
watch it but not all of them just like
with vati who has two points that three
seven and he'll get over half of them to
watch it which for him is over a million
views so that that seems great you know
what I'm saying
there's a clip button next to the like
and dislike and share
I knew that but I didn't know I'm gonna
have to figure out how to view the clips
you guys make
so that would be fun
is it easy to use I don't think I've
ever clipped anything on YouTube before
vati doesn't have your wit
uh I don't know about that
vati has an entire team behind him so
he's ahead of everybody
in that regard
[Music]
to make content for these games like you
kind of need a team
your radagon good vid was very good I
think so too I love that video but you
know it performed not very well in
comparison to all the other ones
I've almost fell in the hole
hello
Bang Bang
[Music]
all the blood vials I could ever want
have you ever played Fallout New Vegas
Yes long time ago when it released
um it's my favorite Fallout for sure
pungent [ __ ] excellent
people watch vati because of his voice
I mean yeah his voice is really nice the
editing's amazing
um
I like how he tells the story
oh oh oh
all right
damn
I just got comboed
into submission my guy
I got hit by a
by that little crawly dude and a bomb
yo that's 20 000.
that goes that we need to go grab
wait it comes back doesn't it okay it
goes that way
that scared me
what up guys I killed all of you already
foreign
lost I'm lost I'm lost I'm lost
I'm lost
please stop following me please please
I'm going this way
do you play Grid in red
guys
can you guys um I like that I like that
the Ito I could be Jato sorry I can't
see the eye but
imagine if we find out mikola is in the
Cocoon
and I called that out
well over a month ago
oh
foreign
I mean I'm gonna be a dick about it I'm
sorry
I'm gonna be a dick about it
I had way too many comments telling me
I'm an idiot
sir I need you to stop I just got here
sir this is a Wendy's I'm gonna need you
to cut it out
foreign
that's what spicy nuggets does to people
I'm just saying I'm gonna be a dick
about it when we find out mikola
is not in the Cocoon
[ __ ] you
every single platform we're gonna need
to call that out
you know how many comments I got of
calling me an idiot
a lot is that gearman
why does that look just like gearman
what are they saying hello
does that not look like gear
someone wrote a 100 page analysis on
bloodborne's lore all words was narrated
and is almost 10 hours long
I love that
hit him again
I hit him three more times
you agree with the comments that it has
to be Nicola
I don't know how it has to be
very high chance of it being so though
I mean it probably is
but if we find out it isn't
gonna make a video about it and the
first word I'm gonna be like I told all
of you this
I told you
I think a good point to bring up on it
is like how did Michala get
I guess he was just already asleep I
don't know
like how did he get caught so easy
Beast don't shoot that
[ __ ] you
foreign
no your mom's cursed idiot
I am lore God bow down to me I called
this out yep
we get a trailer at least close to the
game awards
have leverage against God of War
Ragnarok
I mean we are definitely gonna play
Ragnarok on stream
what oh god
huh
what the [ __ ] you're dead
where's your health at
scared me
he had a body of a child does it anymore
if everyone's saying he's in the Cocoon
I have a fear of snakes too I don't like
snakes
you know why I've only made one video on
rye card that literal reason
I even say that right at the beginning
of the video I don't like snakes
I think this is the shortcut over here
Yep
this device is currently not operable
how about you suck on my wanker
the shortcut for later gotcha I gotta go
down and around
I'm gonna battle my fear
a little scarecrow
why is he walking so fast I hate it
foreign I hate everything about this
guy
Jesus I hate that
die die how about you bloody ass wanker
get out me lot
yeah
you guys like that impression
here it is that's what we want
bloodborne you know what I mean
I'm covered in blood
defeated by a stare
well hello
what's your name ah a new face oh yeah
and an accomplished Hunter you would
appear it would appear so
I am Volta Valdosta of the league I'm
Rick members of The League cleanse the
streets of all the filth that spread
about during the hunt it do be quite
filthy half decent Hunter you know yeah
have you seen enough of these wretched
beasts I have freakish slugs and mad
doctors all trash since these things to
death I have the help of your league
Confederates hell yeah what do you say
why not join the League I should it
sounds good to me yes as a hunter well
should
commit the start why does it look like
he's wearing Confederate blows symbol of
the league
impurity
the night brims with defiled scum and is
permeated by their rotten stench the
greatest thing now you're all set to
hunt and kill to your heart's content
hunt in cooperation with your fellows
your league Confederates
no no no no
I like this guy no there is one thing
you must know
by the oath of the league those who bear
its Rune will see vermic
Vermin writhe deep within all filth and
are the root of man's impurity all
Vermin are to be crushed a grade the
league exists to expunge all vermin
Readiness of any trace of human
corruption and so until we are rid of
all Vermin you must continue to hunt and
kill why not you this bloody fate is
ours alone
do not expect the world to grasp our
work
but remember
the Confederates will always have my
blessing
and each other
always
I like this guy he seems
quite sane
oh we wrapping around
let's go
we gotta go level
Tiff is a little behind I mean
yeah
here's what I think
like lore people of Elden ring right
here's what I think people are having a
hard time grasping the possible concept
of when it comes to lore in Elden ring
sometimes what you are told in game is
not true
does that make sense
sometimes the item descriptions of
whoever wrote them is purposely trying
to deceive you
but a lot of people don't like to think
that
oh look how many of these I have now
holy shh
okay plus 55 plus 60. we need that one
and
but a lot of people don't like to think
that because they like to
think that they know something a hundred
percent come home good Hunter
what is it you desire
and they don't uh want to think that's
possible
foreign
sell the blood gems
[Music]
uh hello I don't know about your name my
guy
May
how did your name get never mind
oh look at all these
foreign
[Music]
what's the profile pic I can't see
why would I be mad it's just like not
appropriate
[Music]
welcome
very well let me
even though I don't think we're very
appropriate here but like Jesus
foreign
[Music]
sell those later if I need to I just
don't think we need
to right now
okay where was I where was I going we
have a shortcut that's right that's
right
right here
[Music]
all these [ __ ] Bots mate
you know what I bet they came from
Latinos
oh I don't like this guy I'm I'm getting
rid of him I don't like him
your viewers are mad bro
go away I don't like people who are like
that dude I just don't like it
what up mate ah there goes your hunt do
not forget the League's mission to
cooperate with Confederates find them
they're actually called Confederates
them out
yes sir
yes sir
somebody in a wheelchair
all right let's keep it going
[Music]
this is not DLC
I go to Yargo already uh I believe
that's the name of the area I went to
yes
where I got captured to go there yeah
we gotta go and do something else before
we can continue through there
oh the guy in the wheelchair is gearman
I didn't know I thought you were talking
about this area
hello
just a little bundle of snakes
I love that that's that's fine
shiny coin I love shiny coin
do any coin make me go yay
foreign
to the next chapter
snake bundle 10.99
you can buy the next bundle the next
snake bundle for 10.99 and you'll
receive a bigger snake
and I'm not talking about your Pekka I'm
talking about the game biggest snake
equals better person right
right
my brain go boom
look bigger snake the snake bundle
amazing
that's so far die
sir you are dead
I'd rather fight Reichard
the snakes count as beasts
[ __ ] that what the hell was that I
didn't think there was actually a bigger
snake bundle holy [ __ ]
laughs
hell no
oh my God
nope nope nope nope
there's a bigger snake down there
throw fire at them
um nope
nope I would rather run away from my
life you know what I'm saying
oh okay dude [ __ ] off please open son of
them
how do I get over there
run
I'm getting some really nice names in
the chat today aren't we
guys I'm just running around right now I
don't know what's going on
dude stop spamming what the [ __ ] man
stop
stop it
I can't pause
oh [ __ ] shut up
go away
okay Jesus
I did the same thing
I am entirely lost
stream wagging I don't think so
so that's locked but I can go this way
that's where I've been
I do not understand people in chat rooms
who just like spam for fun I don't get
it
I'm stuck
foreign
imagine having this life
I'm literally stuck
I cannot move
oh
this didn't help
it's kind of got a nice beat to it
oh oh yeah
foreign
I finally died man I can't freestyle I
Can't Rap you kidding me I wouldn't even
attempt to rap bro I have no idea how
no clue how
emboldened by the flame of blood
I didn't die
shut up sir
like how can you have these names
brother get a life holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
loser
there we go
uh I don't think it was the menu that
killed me
[ __ ] loser dude
and we're just gonna run
you know none of my mods are here right
now
unfortunately
dude never ask how many accounts do you
think these people have they have
endless accounts because they have no
[ __ ] life
they're just losers who sit at their
computer and think they're funny being
racist homophobic
edgy
way so
people
foreign
how people can be that [ __ ] insane
and waste their time doing things like
this
controller trolls that's true
foreign
this stop acknowledging his existence
that's all he's trying to do
um you guys hear that
hi
literal alien
what okay
okay I'm going the wrong way dog
thank you
they're really easy to kill
metamorphosis
I got a stamina item
where do I equip those
foreign
it's not my first playthrough I just
used to speed run so I don't know
everything about the game and it's been
like four or five years
alter in the dream
so I put it on my weapon
like putting on a gym
yeah looks like I can't go anywhere else
can you make accounts this quickly or do
you think he has this many accounts
it's the next Workshop okay
yeah it said metamorphosis
Jesus Christ bro
if only his parents gave him as much
attention as I am right now
then he might not be like this
wait what sorry came
I'm just send that back down anyway
was that another elevator guys I think
it had to have been I think I came from
here
maybe not
it's the elevator to the windmill
yeah this is a different area isn't it
report those accounts to you boys let's
get them IP band
I'm doing each time I'm gonna go up here
I Gotta See
I gotta get a visual in my head
be over there snake
you can't see him anymore
it's because I keep hiding them okay
foreign
it's just because I keep hiding it's
fine
yeah I have ghastly it's pretty cool
now this next time you see him spamming
just report that one
[Music]
okay I'll follow the river
bye ERD have a good one
foreign
yeah I gotta go this way
I'm near the Shadows aren't I the three
shadows
I think
gotta be this Shadows
I hear a piggy
if I pass you
no
me
remember struggling very much on the
Shadows
thank you
is this uh the gate
yep
I guess that's a shortcut
if I remember how to get there
Yep this is the Shadows 100 percent
[ __ ] here we go
I'll just do nothing for now
we got one down
I [ __ ] up I used the wrong thing
I remember this speedrun Strat they keep
stepping to the side if I hit him once
holy [ __ ] I don't like that
holy [ __ ] I don't like that at all
it's like I'm good at the game guys it's
like I'm good at the [ __ ] game first
try not even hard
first try
get them out of here
get him out of here
get get him out of here
I dude as I'm doing the fight I
remembered like he did the side step NYU
used to speedrun it came back up in my
head where I'm like wait if I hit him
once they'll always sidestep
and I can just follow him and hit him
again sidestep hit him again side step
work like a charm still to this day
that's sick
like if I were still speed running this
game I would be so happy with that fight
you could say I'm a pro gamer
like for real Pro Gamer right welcome
home what is it
give me give me give me give me give me
oh let's just get the 30 strength
just because that seems so huge
huge
okay so you guys said blood gem
for the
this one
I want that for sure
hmm
so I have to I don't have the thing
to my left this
oh
raises HP raises stamina
higher blood vial I can have four of
these
or just one oh holy [ __ ]
wait huh
symbol of the Legos
yeah
okay so acquire more blood echoes
pure memory slot two
raises stamina
visceral attacks restore HP
did I just do this one raises HP
visceral attacks Grant more blood Echoes
acquired us more blood echoes in general
HP on visceral
instead of the Moon
okay
that the guy in the wheelchair is
gearman
most of the Holy chalices lie deep
within the tomb oh I forgot to eat my
Apple [ __ ] and the few that found their
way to the surface
were lost again in the hands of men
[Music]
but if the old Hunter Tales remained
true
one of the Holy chalices
is worshiped in the valley Hamlet
[Music]
yet the town is in disarray
it's burned and abandoned for fear of
this no just an apple
now I haven't done any child's dungeons
yet the perfect place for a hunter
wouldn't you say yeah he's the final
boss yes
depends on your ending that you pick
if I remember correctly
goodbye more of these huh
[ __ ] it gimme gimme
bloodshards
Henry oh I can wear Hendrix Hunter [ __ ]
wait his is really good a hundred
give me that
yeah I don't have any more insight
though unfortunately
bodied that one
[Music]
oh huntergarv is 110 though oh
look at that
hello
yarnum hat
I'm stupid no you
oh
I don't like it as much as I thought
[Laughter]
[Music]
rip well now we know
this looks cool
oh yeah I like this way more
yeah I'm dripped
wait different helmet Maybe
Keanu Reeves
let's see
it's good I like the hood
[Music]
okay what do you what do you think where
do we go next do we go to ROM
I think
good morning handgun
wait did I upgrade my
just overall
I need three stone chunkies we need
chunky boys
[Music]
forbidden grave
I don't think I have the charred Hunter
set unless it's that that's just the
hunter set
trunks are post-rom okay got it
I am loving this dude
okay I don't love it as much now get off
me
[ __ ] you
dumbass bug
dumbass [ __ ] bug ass
[ __ ]
little bug ass bug
what's the hardest boss Boston
bloodborne uh orphan a hundred percent I
would say
at least for me orphan of costs is
freaking I remember him being absolutely
Bonkers difficult
in orphan you'll see we'll we'll fight
him
I tried to do a heavy attack there
I think we're pretty damn strong like
we're feeling ourselves right now huh
we can't go to cost right now
[Music]
damn this game just hits with the Vibes
huh
oh I knew something wicked would be back
here bro
why are you so strong
you gotta cut it out
yeah I don't find we're definitely gonna
play uh Dark Souls 3 by the way guys
after we beat bloodborne that's my plan
um I don't find nameless King to be that
hard but he is pretty hard for sure if
you're not leveled properly he is
insane
yep Ronnie's in the moon guys we figured
it out it's Ronnie
Ronnie's ending is bloodborne
isn't that the theory or something
what is that sound I don't like it
um okay
okay I don't know what the [ __ ] that
thing is I don't like it though
please stop everything you're doing
go excellent
877 cash now eight seven seven cash now
what the what the it's a it's a vagina
an explosive vagina
from this gate
I mean doesn't it look like it
it's like a vagina to me
what is this
looks like an elevator
oh [ __ ] I remember you
yep yep yep yep you're an [ __ ] I
remember you
this guy's nuts
what what the f
foreign
that's what that one guy does
be a chest
chest ahead
stop with your mist
let's go
that's a girl
that was a girl
cool
[Music]
slug that's exactly what I wanted
can I open this from here excellent
great chest ahead excellent
what's this
[Music]
student uniform and trousers
summon Henrik I can't summon
the spider hides all manner of rituals
certain to reveal nothing her true
Enlightenment need not be shared
I can't summon them
there's someone right here
you're hitting the no right
when the red moon hangs low the line
between man and Beast is blurred and
when the great ones descend a womb will
be blessed with child
uh excellent pregnancy
guys
you need insight to summon
can I pop a Madman
right
yeah I got 25 of these
um what's that key for
more eyes to open
hello
here why are you up here
oh God
[Music]
let me go
spine
all right we're good
I just pulled an Elden ring I don't want
to talk about it
empty
Phantasm shell
excellent
that's I expected that to be there right
guys
everybody expect the Phantasm
we
that hurt
Arcane buff
if I summon this person are they gonna
try to kill me because it's red
[Music]
what happened to this one can I only
summon one
old Hunter Bell resonates with another
hey yo what up
didn't I just murder you no you're the
other guy who we murdered
he's a Confederate
let's go oh I ran out of insight but I
saw it at least before
right
yeah I think I can only have one summon
whoa oh hello
you're that guy from the cutscene
foreign
did I murder this guy
murder
all of you are saying kill
foreign
I cool
all right
ROM
bring on the spiders
welcome to the fight Henry
holy [ __ ] they hit they hit bro
thank you
remember I gotta hit him on the side
what's happening
I'm scared
[Music]
[Music]
okay
these spiders hit for a ton dog
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ]
okay
[Music]
I'm scared
why do I hear godric
oh that's right card
I just got a ton right there
[Music]
thank you Tom
oh our boy is dead
[Applause]
[Music]
more spiders
[Music]
why are they talking they're talking huh
[Music]
[Applause]
he flopping
foreign
[Applause]
really running low here guys
we gotta get this
[Music]
dog
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so many [ __ ] spiders man
[Music]
I have no more healing
[Music]
okay I got him please please all die
holy [ __ ]
close one
whoa
nice
I did so much damage at the end
hello
first try ROM too let's go
first try shadows and ROM
oh she's bleeding
and crying
oh God
oh here we go guys
we got the red moon
[Applause]
[Music]
no Christ
foreign
disturbing at all
dude I bet there's gonna be people in
our generation that have her dress at
their actual wedding like even have the
blood and stuff that would be sick at a
wedding Tom thank you for the five
dollars as well dude I appreciate you
man I was in the middle of that fight
was intense I had to get real but thank
you dude
I watched out for the comments as much
as a comments for as much as I could
okay hey this is where we were
yep where we were
nothing seems wrong about that
you're our goal oh [ __ ] I I don't have
any heels people
oh yeah this is where the sky
those blood
what about storage HP you can use for a
short time
okay
oh [ __ ] here we go guys oh my God Yep
this this way the game gets real right
here
oh
yeah I'm near a lantern right
I hope so
there we go
oh my God this is so freaking beautiful
yeah should we buy them or should we
like go and
you know what I mean
hey goodbye bot
[Music]
wait new music
[Music]
and the sky's different
[Music]
[Music]
Welcome Home Good Hunter
what is it you desire
can I talk to her like will she tell me
something new Good Hunter
your presence somehow soothes
I sense the ancient Echoes I wish
someone would say that about me where's
your veins
very well let me stand
the the music in this game
has to be
the best music in all of Gaming
[Music]
I think
this might be a hot take there are some
songs in Elden ring that are beautiful
you're worth in the waking world but I
don't think it holds up the bloodborne
maybe he'll tell us more the healing
Church
and the blood ministers who belong to it
were once Guardians I like the ROM teams
in the times of the Hunter
Ludwig Ludwig they worked and forged
weapons
[Music]
today
that they have much to offer you
and so I cannot wait to listen to
Ludwig's OST bro
s
[Music]
Odin Chapel we've been there right
see if we got new clothes
we can purchase twin bone shards now
um
oh I want his cap
cool
let's see what other runes we have
I make additional discoveries
is that one really that good
I for gearman's theme
and Ludwig's OST I am literally not
gonna talk and I'm going to turn the
music to 10.
thousand percent
oh for lore okay
oh these are Roots I
uh display a secret symbol left by Carl
Carl rootsmith of bergenworth
transcription of I has spoken
by Left Behind great ones allows one to
make additional discoveries eyes
symbolize the truth Master Wilhelm saw
it in his research disillusioned by the
limits of human intellect Master Willem
oh God
I burp mid-sentence Master Willem looked
to beans from higher planes for guidance
and sought to lined his brain with eyes
in order to elevate his thoughts
that's [ __ ] badass
okay we need to buy
s
how many I can get
it's cool
did I sell the other
like these
I'll sell them later we're fine we're
we're pretty strong we'll get blood
Echoes as well
foreign
okay
[Music]
do we go back to the Unseen Village
I got the sniffles all of a sudden
yo what up Cameron
grilled cheese
or it would now be the time to go to the
DLC
how long you stream before I am I don't
plan on stopping anytime soon
I always just go until I'm done
holy [ __ ]
you've shot me
okay there's a lot of people why are
they like exploding with blood now
you see that
whoa
oh
[Music]
see bloodborne Port realistic probably
not
I hope so though
but probably not unfortunately
they would have done it by now
oh boy
my health back
my eyes
[Music]
got him got her got her we're good
oh
don't you guys I should be the voice
actor
oh there's a hole in the wall right
there
hello
whoa where did you come from
okay we gotta kill the lady
okay I am running by and I am killing
the lady
I don't know why I have the sniffles all
of a sudden sorry how's bloodboard been
as good as I remember it
the best Souls game available
I would put eldering as the best open
world game ever
but this is the best Souls game
this might be the best game ever made
so they all die yep cool
dog what are you typing
guys like trying to type motivational
[ __ ] in the chat I don't understand what
are you doing
like talk like a normal person I'm just
gonna get rid of you
okay
run run
all right where you at
is that a lady staring in the corner
no
I don't get out of here
we go
lady where are you
there you are
not a part of her I see
[Music]
please tell me you've listened to a
sneak peek of Cthulhu Seekers for Dawn
theme of course of course
Cthulhu Seeker is freaking amazing
what up JayBird
oh he's still there but he doesn't want
to attack me anymore
[Music]
oh what am I hearing right now I don't
like it I don't like it
cut it out
oh oh oh oh
we're just shooting laser beams out here
[ __ ] laser beams man oh
[Music]
holy [ __ ] whoa
thank you
what fire hit me there
do I gotta book it through here
they're respawning yeah we do
foreign
excellent
I did not make it
I did I did not make it
I'm having an allergy attack right now
no cap holy [ __ ]
okay I did unlock a shortcut however
there that is good
thank you
run run run
and run
run run run
I'm done
and we're back
yeah placidusac's laser
so it's not the actual laser
it's the explosion thereafter
booking it running as fast as I can
we good oh hello
thank you
oh I want to murder you though
and it's gone okay
is 4K 60fps patch too much to ask
apparently
if they sold that for 20 bucks would you
buy it
if they sold it for 60 bucks I'd buy it
damn that's a 20K poppable
I should have used two
oh why are you up there
come here
welcome
very well
I want you guys to think about this
there is no reason for them not to
remake this game or at least do a 60 FPS
patch right it's been years people have
been asking for this or to put it on PC
right
they don't care about that stuff
they like making new games
which is why I think they might not make
the Elden ring DLC but
I'd love it if they did both things I
would love if they happen
but they kind of proved that they don't
really care about money
you know
that's just my weird take on it
that nobody likes
scene Village
is this the new one I was at
[Music]
I don't think DLC would be disappointing
foreign
I mean this game came out seven years
before Elden ring Oh wrong one
wrong one
gotta go back
they remastered Dark Souls they
remastered it very very poorly
to a point of where I wouldn't even say
it's
is pretty much dog [ __ ]
let's go here
[Music]
oh getting no DLC with you this morning
of course of course yeah
we all want it
question is is it gonna happen
I think yes
but
they've kind of proven they don't care
much about money
oh God here we go
anything but dogs where are you at
die
[Music]
the remake of demon souls was great
yes that was great
that's something like entirely different
would you rather have bloodborne
remastered or bloodborne 2 at this point
bloodborne 2.
I mean I'm playing it right now and I'm
enjoying it
foreign
don't kill me in this corner please
they just go like insane
you're attacking me
original Demon Souls is better than the
Remake the Remake is great in many ways
but it fails to capture many of the
intentions
behind the original design choices I
never played the original so I don't I
don't know if that's the case
I only played the remake
and even finish it
still need to
our developers a bloodborne actually
dying
whoa
what is this
why is this Lantern like
this Lancer to fake the [ __ ]
uh
who this
hello
are you mean
okay I'm getting jumped
there already is a bloodborne d-make
okay bro
I just got jumped
foreign
the 18.
Patrol
what does this say nightmarish rituals
Rave a newborn find one in silence it's
harrowing cry
oh Tom let's go
vessel from these three has the same
design as the Giant's flame same twin
Birds and the black flame within Frida
is a byproduct of bloodletting in the
Resurrection The Soul is within the
flood Echoes Smiley cat face the soul is
within the blood echoes
stop
help
Tom thank you man I really appreciate
you dude
I am a nightmare
realm right now
all the doors open let's go
but thank you Tom you're the man
same design as the Giant's Flame
oh [ __ ] I just got sniped
foreign
things are scaring me dude
bro
oh here we go dude
you hear all that whispering
all this is happening is because I
killed a spider spider huh
Darkness
yeah it's literally Neato
true
it looks like my [ __ ] I took this
morning
killing it with fire
now
is this his head too
foreign
what's he screaming about bro
[Music]
he's dropping his Gunk on me
am I at the wrong end
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
am I just like really good at this game
or like what's going on man
I think I'm just like [ __ ] jacked
like cheese
Pro Gamer
I killed that thing so fast that
I didn't even hear the second half of
its song
just built different
it's because I'm eating an apple
[Music]
dude the music change in this area when
you beat ROM
is such a nice [ __ ] touch
such a nice touch
what is it you did
very well
yeah I'm scared of doctors bro are you
not doctors are scary dude they can tell
you some bad [ __ ]
I'm gonna eat my goddamn Apple
[Music]
here let me grab a tissue real quick I'm
literally having an allergy attack
no I'm not allergic to apples bro
I just like apples
[Music]
okay I'm like on track
hey dude that's so true in such the case
with like every boss we fight Miss Miss
Misfit
is uh
all these bosses that we fight are
literally minding their own business and
then we just show up
and in their day
okay what else can I do where else can I
go
here
[Music]
yes I am allergic to peanuts
that's another game I've never played a
Shadow of the Colossus
I've heard of it though
oh [ __ ] is this that guy
this is disturbing
inspect mummy
mummy
mama
you're unintentionally hurting them hey
I got a trophy poggers
hosts of The Nightmare
what's his name again mikolash
if I remember correctly this boss sucks
right
they're spraying me with [ __ ]
I'm over it
I'm over that [ __ ]
the nameless Moon presence beckoned by
Lawrence and his associates paleblood
three third chords
I gotta sneeze
okay I'm not sneezing
I'm just dying inside oh hello
whoa
whoa thank you I didn't actually sneeze
I just thought I did I don't know what's
happening
my I'm getting annihilated my nose is
dead
holy [ __ ]
you know just a crying baby no problem
look at this nightmare fuel of a thing
just went to the ground
we are in The Nightmare boys we are in
the nightmare
you missed an NPC running backward
running to the NPC
running
hello
oh in the lecture hall well
that
you guys think Hideki had like some
really bad dreams and it resulted in all
of these games
are you [ __ ]
hello
foreign
wow very cool
nice
that's not terrifying at all
the UK is bloodborne
I've never been
oh Chad I am dying right now I don't
know what's going on I need another
tissue
get it out
of my nose bro
uh
okay
I've never seen or read berserk
just say no to your allergies
I'll remember that next time
[Music]
um should we go talk to the NPC
I don't think I've ever seen an NPC in
here
foreign
okay I'm being
whatever's happening to me right now is
not okay okay
Ladder near the Giant
on it
[Music]
oh
what is that
is this [ __ ] patches
it is you count on me no way did this
come to pass
now wait just a moment
do you think you'll love me me
of course I think I love you
yeah your [ __ ] patches [ __ ] you
hey it's me to hear it
you've made yourself a misrecked me
I shared with you a thing most secret
now you're witness to a miracle
and all the stronger for it
laying as a Pikes I've never seen this
say in my house I know patches was a
spider in this game but I've never
actually seen him well you weren't a no
and it wasn't for you tonight to sign
like some lore videos as well that ends
well I say
laughs
God
no matter
such details are trifling
we're Fast Friends by now
let this Express what words cannot
anti-clockwise metamorphosis that doubt
me not sweet compare
what is friendship
but a chance encounter it's a Pog [ __ ]
yeah
ah well met
my apologies
but I feel a profound thought occurred
on the good grace of a certain God and
the way he meted out is love
bro
so creepy
whoa
that's just larvid
it's been done
it's been done guys
the lore of this game
I could not expand on any further than
it already has
amygdala
oh we fight amygdala in the DLC
which is here
nightmare Frontier baby
[Applause]
oh
[ __ ]
we fight amygdala there
right yeah
I hear the baby oh wait this is not DLC
isn't it
what's the DLC called again I thought it
was called nightmare Frontier
I'm gonna go upgrade
Hunter's nightmare that's what I'm
thinking of
welcome
what is it here
very well the old Hunters
not what I want to do I want to go up
here
man's gone
it's not good we need one more chunk
we can honestly go find that where's
gearman
welcome home what is it dude
Good Hunter
I sent you already said that
foreign
[Music]
we did get grabbed I think we got
grabbed too early right
okay let's go back
so should we do nightmare Frontier or
let's just get this over with
[ __ ] it
wait this still affects me oh
run
run
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm out
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm out
oh yeah these whale boys that throw
rocks
foreign
legit just follows me all the way here
go away thank you
God damn it
I don't like spiders either
give me a knowledge
that's a big chunky spider
no no no no
we running
we running
away
from all that [ __ ]
whoa
okay
there's one bright moon
why
fight
okay okay
there were more spiders
misfit
thank you for becoming an Elden Lord I
appreciate that very much
thank you very much sir welcome to the
agency
I just got annihilated into next week
let's try that again
this is terrifying
spiders really don't play around man
yeah
did I even fight that guy on the bridge
not if there's a bunch of spiders coming
after me that's for sure
but that is just awful
does this armor suck or am I getting
getting hit by a lot by everything
foreign
ERS they're all chonking in there
looks like they're stuck
I'm gonna ignore
really
he just celebrated did you see that he's
celebrating what the hell
I'm getting hit by a lot
foreign
I'm running past that guy
yeah is this armor like not very good
XD it's a one tenor just like all this
50 I mean
this could be this is really good this
armor is really good I'm getting hit by
all for a lot
nah naked sounds bad
okay we are running for our life we are
non-stop running
we will not fight the guy on the bridge
yes coin armor
[ __ ] I like the way I look
schemes mostly about looks anyway right
[Music]
like armor doesn't do too much
get out of the way
oh yeah I don't like this at all nope
get me the [ __ ] out of here
nope
nope nope
foreign
don't do it please hit the elevator body
hit the button
no
bloodborne drip is goated you do look
very cool
this area hits for a lot man
die so quickly
wait isn't the shortcut over here
or was that what I was about to get
me the whale boys
oh there's a lantern right here let's go
it's something
yup I needed to hit the elevator didn't
I
oh
you go back
wait they can die to it as well that's
funny
what am I gonna be for Halloween
foreign
probably nothing I don't dress up for
Halloween
I'm lame
what are you gonna be for Halloween
all the drugs
all of the drugs
it's gonna be Arwen
from Attack on Titan
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
we're running out here
we going crazy
oh Lord of the Rings
how the [ __ ] does that one shot me man
I'm right here again
the same [ __ ] spot
damn it
foreign
nuts
I gotta run all the way this way again
okay
roll that way this is the die right at
the end
foreign
foreign
why is everything hitting me for a
billion all of a sudden
foreign
nothing
it's the loudest
oh my God Brian stop holy [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
there we go
foreign
so it's like just a okay I get it that's
cool
okay
foreign
never ever
okay I'm a full heal here
we get one bonked again
foreign
I don't know why I can't Dodge that
woman but I just can't
okay
better knock that down actually
it's a dog Crow
dude she means nothing but business
yes Brian I know there's another
shortcut here
please stop telling me where everything
is please
thank you
oh God
okay well we've told you several times
to stop but you keep doing it
I am playing my game I will find the
things
I get stuck places and I ask
help would be greatly appreciated but I
did not ask
I want that item
come here [ __ ] I didn't jump
okay that's not good
what a void Tech how are you I don't
think I can get in there
now my eyes itchy [ __ ] I'm having a
legit allergy attack
foreign
dude even these guys hit me for so much
okay why are people telling me how to
play the game I don't get it
I'm trying to get the shortcut here
before I go in there
there we go
foreign
what
oh I can pull it down from down there
got it
okay let's do it
this is not New Game Plus
foreign
the job button is nice isn't it
oh are you shall not abandon the dream
now one can catch us no one can stop us
now
hahaha
I did not miss this guys
voice
at all
[ __ ] you
foreign
no he will run away from us the entire
fight pretty much
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
there you are
[Music]
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God no I want to pick up the item
not skip his dialogue [ __ ]
[Music]
he's in here
[ __ ] you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's like I'm playing the second half of
[ __ ] Elden ring dude [ __ ]
just insta kills me
God damn
have a good one gasly
I really need to see where you guys got
a
cause you guys said you've been making
Clips but I don't know how to look at
them
after the stream is over
I wonder if there's like a tab
can I knock this down
oh I can just do that that's perfect
I thought I couldn't get out if I press
the button
yeah I have to do all that again
might bolt him
see if it does more damage
get out of my way
thank you
now you're stuck aren't you
'll fight out here
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
no go in the room
what
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
did all my damage all my health
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like why does that hit me sometimes
not every time
look at that that one of them hit me and
it's all
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
what the [ __ ]
this is such horseshit
[Music]
hey this didn't work that time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
done
awful boss
worst boss in the game for sure
[Music]
Jesus
uh definitely like a cool lore boss but
man the fight is so annoying
good music too
all right
okay Kai just runs away
[Music]
guys this is running away it's so epic
iron door key
wait could I have opened the door just
by getting that key
is that for a different door
well we beat the boss so we're good
thank you Moon
other door okay
oh
sniffles are killing me
yeah but I look so cool I don't want to
change my clothes
just take me back
is there a randomizer for bloodborne no
I don't think so
this is on Playstation so I don't know
how to hack a
console
yeah
I don't think you can actually
oh I bet you could I just don't know how
welcome home what is it
very well let me stand
okay strength
is is Arcane what gives us more defense
yeah physical defense
that seems actually good to have right
I'll throw a couple more in there since
it's pretty [ __ ] low farewell Good
Hunter
thank you
grab eight of these boys
see if we can upgrade anything or change
our gems around
yep
seven more chunks
a gem
[Music]
on that
good
oh this puts bolt on our thing though no
I think I like this better look at there
yeah I don't want to jailbreak my
PlayStation no thanks
okay
[Music]
ergo's Loft
base in Middle
where was I at there
I'm gonna go pee real quick guys I'll be
right back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I have returned
[Music]
why would I wash my hands when I got a
clean dick
[Music]
then why is it when I upgraded my Arcane
that my physical defense went up
prove it no
[Music]
okay we're going middle
foreign
only I get to know
we already going at it out here
uh okay let's see
do more chunky boys what's happening to
me what what
get out of my face
it was obnoxious
I hear the baby
are those the Shadows what the [ __ ]
oh yeah
where does this go
wait why would I go here
seems kind of worthless
oh yeah
just realized it stayed open
[Music]
inflicted organ
oh God
that thing sounds like absolute
nightmare fuel
running
stop looking at me
I see a lever over there
foreign
I think it's called madness in this game
sure
doesn't matter
try that again
are you [ __ ] kidding me
thank you
excellent
oh no no
they're called madness and Elden ring
what the [ __ ]
I'm like feel like I'm diving out right
when I'm in line with it and I'm way
above it for some reason
huh
I mean I feel like rolling should just
be fine but okay
it clearly like hoists me back up for
some reason
like I get stuck on the gate
okay
like the roll hoists me up it's weird
sound is terrifying
foreign
go
oh okay
whoa
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this doesn't help I don't know why I'm
hiding behind something
oh don't don't you dare you [ __ ]
I wanted to take the sedative
okay what I'm gonna do is in stream for
today because there's just a bunch of
back seaters in here now telling me what
to do and I don't like it
but we'll be back tomorrow
probably to beat the game tomorrow
I don't know why so many back seaters
came in toward the end of the stream
that's weird but anyway
parking lot flooding with rain but
Jake's stream is priority awesome thank
you Garrett
I'm out of here guys I'm having an
allergy attack still and now I feel like
poop
because you suck okay well now I don't
like you so what was your what were you
going for there buddy
this guy here I mean I've been streaming
for four and a half hours so
you can re-watch it if you want to
it's always the case
um more than likely be back tomorrow
around the same time
and then
let's see
got some cool stuff on the horizon but I
think we can beat bloodborne tomorrow
I'm pretty sure maybe maybe two more
streams depending but anyway I will
catch you guys later thank you for being
here appreciate y'all
and we'll be back have a good one peace
out